relatos desgarradores de las víctimas
del conflicto en República democrática
del Congo llegaron a oídos del Papa
Francisco
tenía 16 años en aquel momento y fui
retenida como esclava sexual y abusada
durante tres meses cada día usaban de
cinco a diez hombres de cada una de
nosotras nos hacían comer la pasta de
maíz y la carne de los hombres
asesinados
Francisco respondió con un llamado a
detener la violencia y los abusos
hago un llamado De corazón a todo el
pueblo a todas las organizaciones
internas y externas que orquestan la
guerra en la República democrática del
Congo para saquear azotar y
desestabilizar al país se están
enriqueciendo con la explotación ilegal
de los bienes de este país y con el
brutal sacrificio de víctimas inocentes
quitad las armas poner fin a la guerra
suficiente dejen de enriquecerse a Costa
de los pobres dejen de enriquecerse con
recursos y dinero manchado de sangre
previo a este encuentro el papa realizó
una gran misa campal donde se estima
acudieron un millón de personas el país
lleva décadas en medio de conflictos en
su mayoría ocasionados por el control de
bastos de nacimientos minerales entre el
gobierno y Los Rebeldes además por las
secuelas del genocidio de Ruanda de 1994
unos 6 millones han muerto en las
últimas décadas según el comité
internacional de rescate 5,7 millones
han sido desplazados internamente y 26
millones se enfrentan a una hambruna
grave en los próximos meses según
Naciones Unidas luego de Esta visita que
no se daba desde que Juan Pablo II
estuvo en esta tierra en 1985 Francisco
se dirigirá a Sudán del sur